كل شيء في كل مكان دفعه واحده
الفيلم الذي توج بجائزه افضل فيلم في حفل
توزيع جوائز الاوسكار رغم انه لم يكن
فائزا محتملا بوصفه ابعد ما يكون عن السرد
القصصي التقليدي اذ تدوروا قصته حول
مهاجره صينيه في منتصف العمر تتورط في
مغامره مجنونه تستطيع فيها وحدها انقاذ
الوجود من خلال استكشاف اكوان اخرى ويبدو
ان الفيلم حصل على كل شيء في كل مكان دفعه
واحده
[تصفيق]
فقد نالت بطلته الممثله الماليزيه ميشيليو
جائزه افضل ممثله رئيسيه وهي اول فائزه
اسيويه على الاطلاق في هذه الفئه
[موسيقى]
وفاز مخرج الفيلم دانيال كوان ودانيال
بجائزه افضل اخراج وكانت جائزه افضل
سيناريو اصلي من نصيبهما ايضا اضافه الى
جائزه افضل ممثل مساعد التي نالها الممثل
ممثله مساعده لجيميلي كيرتز الحدث الذي
تترقبه الساحتان الفنيتان الامريكيه
والعالميه بشوق كل عام شهد مفاجاه غير
متوقعه اخرى وهي فوز الممثل الكندي براندن
فريزر بجائزه افضل ممثل عن دوره في فيلم
الحوت
جائزه اوسكار لافضل صوت كانت من حصه فيلم
عوده قويه لبطله توم كروز الذي تعلم
الطيران ليستطيع اداء دوره في العمل الذي
حقق ارباحا كبيره
حصل فيلم حديث النساء ومن تاكن على جائزه
افضل سيناريو مقتبس وهو من اخراج وسيناريو
ساره بولي ويدور حول العديد من القضايا
النسائيه
اما جائزه افضل مؤثرات بصريه فكانت من
نصيبي فيلم افاتار 2 وافضل فيلم اجنبي
بنظري هيئه التحكيم كان الفيلم الالماني
كل شيء هادئ على الجبهه الغربيه تدور
احداثه حول اهوال حرب الخنادق بعين جندي
شاب
اكاديمي اوردس المعروفه باسم جوائز
الاوسكار والتي تمنح سنويا من قبل
اكاديميه فنون وعلوم الصور المتحركه هي
جوائز للجداره الفنيه والتقنيه في مجال
صناعه السينما وتعد بمثابه اعتراف دولي
بالامتياز في الانجازات السينمائيه وفقا
لتقييم اعضاء التصويت في الاكاديميه